[Music]
um all those in favor
against that is carry
thank you for working through that
another stopping
okay that takes us to the shopping
uh Greenhouse so thanks Mr chairman this
is another stopping of a piece of
unformed road at Green Hills and and
this is I guess the commencement of the
process where we will follow the Local
Government Act to start that
consultation process
a piece of land
um though the piece of road is bounded
by um
well or the owner on either side the
same owner as appears on either side of
the road so he currently has
um effective use of the road and I guess
this is part of a process to start to
say are we able to stop this road and I
guess this request to council is is to
actually just start that consultation
process right that's pretty
straightforward questions
just a quick one Russell would that
imply that he would then have exclusive
right to the road once it's stopped from
a city council perspective he wouldn't
have to buy it would he was it he's
suggesting he may stick
once the processes you've stopped you've
stopped the road you then decide decide
on how you dispose of it the road is
still Council owned you know and you
will need to um just dispose of it in an
approved manner in accordance with
Council policy
and that typically or often is the case
where it's actually disposed of but that
meets the cost of disposal okay yeah
thank you further questions is Miss Cook
yeah it's a piece of land at the end of
the
unformed Road
um which I can't tell who is the owner
of
um or what the purpose of it is it looks
like at some stages
must brought it onto
set the piece that's on the east side of
the road on the right yeah it also it
looks like it's either water or sand or
something at the bottom of the thing I
can't actually tell I don't have got
good enough definition but I just
wondered if that if anybody else owned
it who required access would they be
ordered the does this piece of land have
an alternative access is really what I'm
asking I suppose this piece of piece of
land goes between the state highway and
an end lot on the western end so it
actually is bounded it has
it is actually land Bound by the past
also
it has no other it has no other access
points to any other other than the piece
on the um there is a there is a section
to the the west of it that people may
have an interest and I guess that's this
process
right
for the questions
now if that's the case then the
recommendations
that this committee received the report
and that the this committee notes that
the portion of unformed Roadshow and
appendix one is not required for writing
activity and that infrastructure
committee also sorry approves the
commencement of the consultation to
consider the stopping of that portion of
unformed legal Road at Bluff Highway
Green Hills measuring approximately 830
square meters per section 342 of the
local government
act I'm going to put that motion all
those oh sorry I need a movement for
that oh
moved my counselors over second by
councilor Ludlow put the emotional loads
in favor
against that is caring thank you for
that that takes us we've got two final
reports really to get through the first
one is the
uh City
streets closed circuit TV report
Street
no no you've got a Koto uh I will take
the reporters read but I'm happy to
share with the committee that Scott Bain
from safer cities has uh joined
with us is the project manager for this
piece of work we kicked off the first
meeting this afternoon prior to this
committee meeting and we are aligning
the next time he can visit invercargill
and we will once we have that in place
we'll be able to meet with the different
stakeholders to start the identification
of where we can invest in our CCTV in
the Central City
I'm happy to answer any questions
okay
um questions
yes you just look through this and it's
good to see the report through the
discussions was there any suggestion
that the police could
increase their own presence within the
city is that something that was
discussed yeah that was
enjoying the workshop
counselor it is a
I can't speak for the police but from
the feedback we had from them they have
challenges with having the right
resources in the right place at the
right time where if they have access to
the CCTV Vision they're able to
establish where they can sense send
something if they see something
inappropriate occurring
okay thank you
any further comments or questions just
counselor being on the committee Mr
skill
thank you thank you thank you truly for
the work that's been done
um I guess some of the feedback is in
noted through the media the time frames
around the CCT building project and
obviously um it's all takes time
um just given that situation we were
currently at do you see any acceleration
of time frame that could be or some room
for to accelerate
we we wanted to be realistic with the
time frame and pragmatic given the
problems we'd have with Supply
potentially uh
Scott is confident that we can deliver
within the 11 months but it planning is
key it's all very well putting in a
system it's the most important thing to
do for us is to make sure we have a good
plan of where the cameras are so that
it's not all for nothing and that we use
the right technology that gives us uh so
we're future proof we will do everything
possible to accelerate the project where
we can but at this early or earlier
stage I it would be foolish of me to
promise something I can't deliver
thank you for the update
uh Council lady
question of ignorance is there any
possibility of staging its
implementation
we will we would know that once we've
had further information from our project
manager who may be able to establish
something like that that's a question
you can ask them yes it is thank you
I think uh just like the comment um
I'd like to thank actually the Chamber
of Commerce who actually uh
um did a open workshop on this um safety
in the city and that's where I think
Scott Payne came to and spoke I was
actually there just as a as in the
audience and I think you've made a very
good choice uh
um I spoke briefly with them afterwards
and and he's um he's quite unique uh in
his skill base and he's done so many
projects both overseas and in New
Zealand and I think you that's that's a
very I can comment a very good choice of
of person
um to get this thing underway who's sort
of been there done that and and this to
him is sort of like his day job yeah
which is really really good
so that that gives me a lot of
confidence thank you Council clack yeah
I was at the meeting as well and um
and I guess there was there seemed to be
two two sets of or a set of tensions and
and who would fund each we had certainly
a desire to have the inner city safe and
that that was quite a reasonable
expectation but the police also wanted
two things they wanted license
identification technology so they could
pick up number plates and they also
wanted some sort of um
cctvs on arterial roads leading to and
from
um the general city area so that they
could track criminals coming and going
actually before they
um before they got to commit their
crimes and us and so that led on to some
sort of discussion about well if you
want that for an overall police
um prevention issue maybe you should
fund some of it and make a little bit of
tension then I guess about who would
fund what what components and whether
we'd be involved with the license
identification which is it kicks a bit
of cost into the project I think and the
big RTA road so to be out on the out by
the Ascot Hotel and places like that
there's people coming into the city
so be good if that was clarified
right
sorry so the focus of this project is on
the Central City that wider context of
cameras across the city and at arterial
routes we will need to progress as a
separate piece of work yep that's
outside of this project at this time
as well being part of the cvd Focus that
you're saying that's going to be a
second phase we we will need to make
sure that we fund or work through what
that would look like first so what
problem we're trying to solve because
it's also you've got the shopping area
of Windsor and you've also got Bluff so
it's being mindful that
um we cover the right and even waikiwi
yeah so
um we will have to work through that and
understand the costings and the and work
through that either the annual plan or
the long-term plan process for that
piece of work thank you
um Leslie who you don't want to speak
just
I was also at the meeting but for
technological reasons was unable to
continue to be at the meeting because
the
um the zoom capacity for some reason
meant that no one could hear me so
that's why I'm recorded as an apology
however the part of the meeting I was
and I really just wanted to comment the
um I think that this whole conversation
has now gone into the phasing side of
things we're at the very early stage of
the commencement of this project we know
it has the potential to be quite a a
large and expanded project the phasing
is going to be crucial to how we
progress from here and I think it's it's
too early to make more than the general
comments treaties made at this stage
about um how we can incorporate those
other areas thank you yeah that is at
this stage and we've got to think about
this from a community perspective in
Community Development perspective
um some for some people
CCTV is not welcomed so there's equal
sides okay one thing I can comment on
from sort of being in the industry was
that the brains of the equivalent the
heart of the system
for the CBD is not limiting to any
expansion that councilor Clark talked
about so that's the thing that no one
needs to worry about is that whatever
gets done first is not prohibitive to
expansion
just money
yes cancel those [ __ ] just a very quick
contrary to your record I sent an email
I've mentioned the bluff people had
already put a radar up about it yes
thank you counselor I appreciate that it
was above 2020
right
we'll use that pipeline yeah
okay any further questions about CCTV
um the recommendations quite
straightforward that we received the
report
um can I have a move for that move of
that moved councilor Scout seconded
council Ludlow for the emotional as in
favor
aye against that's Carrie thanks tree
right that leaves the last report which
is on Solid Waste
Mr Nolan
welcome
you've got up to two hours
so um from the last meeting I'll get you
to ring the microphone slice it thanks
so from the last meeting I said I
provide an update in terms of the data
and uh on the movement forward with a
plan
so uh what we've done I've looked at the
last five years Trend and we've seen
that the trend for Waste has been going
up overall
um but while we've also found is that uh
there's been this month this this month
has been a significant increase in
recycling
and there's been a reduction in waste
now that that's compared I've compared
that year on year overall
waste on recycling that's actually
dipped this month compared to the
previous years too
now you might ask why am I comparing
this one month against previous years
because it doesn't really form a pattern
this is just a flavor of the of the um
reporting we'll be bringing to to this
committee into the future as we move
through and we become uh more
sophisticated in our understanding of of
the waste streams
um
so that's that's the data side of it in
terms of the plan progress we've engaged
the Consultants
and they've come through they've
reviewed the wmmp
they've provided a report to us in terms
of their progress
and they've given us some times
and by the seventh of October they will
have done a full full analysis on the
report
and they would have developed the
short-term Community engagement plan
ready for us to go out in terms of
providing the education under the bit
bits of pieces that's required to help
reduce waste as we move forward into the
future
with regards to the
[Music]
um
sorry
with regards to the uh review of the
wmmp we spoke with
um MFE and they're quite satisfied that
we had fulfilled our obligations in
terms of the review and we're quite able
to
ask for the labian they will provide us
the levy so we've done what we needed to
do with the in terms of the review
write questions
Council Club
um yeah I've got a few questions
um I noticed at the end of the report
you say you understand that recycle
South is relocating to Macario
um and I guess as the one side of the
contract we should know where they're
moving shouldn't we
are they definitely going to we we
understand that they they don't want to
tell us more more than that right now
okay so that that then leads on to a
couple of questions
um one is is the issue that we don't
have any recycling
um or any any waste collection out of
NoDa Tara which has grown quite large
now it's probably 10 of the population
live there or somewhere close
um and so all the people that live out
there either have private arrangements
with different collectors
um and certainly uh have to make their
own
um recycling
um arrangements so some some do that
probably with those other contractors
others take it down to the current Depot
and put it through the slots I guess one
of the things that will worry me from a
city perspective was or Council
perspective is if they're moving one
whether we have some say over that and
and two what the impact will be for
those that currently recycle from areas
where they don't have a pickup situation
so they don't have curbside
and thirdly whether
a place as big as odotara and this may
be something for after the next election
should
um should we canvas whether there's a
desire to have it because there'll be an
increase to their costs of course
I mean when you consider I assume as
soon we pick up from Bluff which is 30
K's way and yet six K's away we don't do
any pickup at all
um so I mean I'm not asking for a
response to that now but I think it's
just flagging something for the future
the other issue you've got in the on the
same page is the issue that Bond you
hold the curbside
contract have have offered a contract
price for checking the bins which is
something we haven't done for several
years now
um and but your report doesn't actually
say whether we're sort of keen to to
adopt that we we've asked them to do a
sort of Broken Glass safety report
but I mean I wouldn't have thought
that's a huge risk for people that are
just checking the bins they just use
some sort of mechanism poke it in and
see whether it's the wrong product on
the wrong bin as opposed to the risks
that come to the recycling plant itself
where they've got the shards of glass
so are we opened a
considering a contract from Bond
uh yes we're speaking with on we've
asked them to conduct a safety risk
assessment because of uh Sharps from
syringe needles and and glass okay and
certainly the process of inspecting bins
uh because if you just open the top
people put things on oh sure you don't
understand it so through these
Consultants we've asked them to provide
a process of an inspection so which we
can then provide to the contractor to
provide us within a feedback okay and
and the last question it relates to the
um you say there's a new or suggested
waste resourcing structure there subject
to consultation
um of a manager coordinator and a
commercial contracts manager so is that
a structure for the city or for the
wider waste net group and and who's the
consultation going to be with sure so
it's uh for both the city and the on The
Wider wastenet group okay and the
consultation was with the waste
management group will bring that forward
that they they've agreed to adopt that
that resource and we've we feel that we
really need this to drive through the
waste minimization and put the plans in
place that we want to bring forward and
certainly um to to get into the real
data analysis so we can really
understand what's going on so so when
you say that they have agreed you mean
the other two councils have agreed the
two councils and they'll share the cost
of course won't just sit with us indeed
okay thank you
um for the questions
yes let's go
um I'm just
sorry I've had to shut my iPad it's I'm
turned itself off it's given up
um it's just tired
um if we talk about
the contract that we have for the
recoverable materials and the contract
or the provider of that service
wouldn't they not just notify us and due
course what their new property placement
is be is it any business of ours if they
make a personal or pragmatic decision to
relocate for their own reasons and
should we even be discussing or whether
it I mean is it any of our business that
they're making that decision what impact
does it have on us
because I was a little bit concerned
about this idea well they you know they
shouldn't they consult us well
they're they're an
during a service to us for which we pay
a contract Free Labor contract but do we
we don't dictate where they should
locate it surely
no you mean you raise a valid point yeah
um councilor Clark and Council yeah sure
uh we we should consult well they should
consult with us because it's not just a
matter of where they provide it
otherwise they could go and provide and
Dunedin or or go around where they're
like part of what they provide is not
just the recycling function but they
they also have a drop-off center where
people in otatara and people in the city
because I regularly use it people in a
city who bring along stuff that they
can't put into their bins or their bins
are overflowing and they bring along and
they push up through those slots so if
the plants at Macarena we will lose that
capacity and people may then dispose of
it in ways that we don't want
but they might start stuffing it on the
general landfill thing and putting
Plastics into there so I mean look we we
get on well with them and what our
feedback I hear from sdu is that they
get on well with council at the moment
which is great but there are some
impacts of them just moving
because if we lose that function of
being able to go down here and just
stuff cardboard or polyurethane or
whatever through those slots that goes
and if you don't have any bins then
you've got no other option it'll it'll
go into the general anthem or people
will just dump it places yeah but as as
chair I think was talking about
something purely hypothetical here and
and really that's that I wouldn't
encourage any debate on that at all
um thank you Mr chair thank you Mr chair
that's exactly what I was going to say
yeah I just think we just leave that and
and whatever happens we we face those
things uh one question I have
Peter is
um regarding our
ETS tax which is a huge portion of the
landfill now moving forward and and with
this consultant and adopting a new wmmp
and looking at options of waste
diversion minimization everything
how do we what's your workings with me
Fe to understand the rules around
can we knock down that hundred hundred
dollars a ton value if we so if we get a
ton of bricks which is a nerd are they
going to charge us for GR you know
Carbon emission from a brick or is there
is there actually play I mean we need to
know the rules and do you our MFE coming
forward to actually let you know how you
can you know before you actually truly
divert do compost stuff like that are we
going to see
um savings for us do you know like
dealing with them uh Mr uh I haven't
spoken to MFE about this but the way the
contract is structured is that um
the uh the operator on the owner of the
landfill they they currently um take the
risk on it uh again this is one of the
activities we are to look at into the
future as we evolve in the waste space
on how we can improve
um us as a smart smart buyer into in
terms of accessing services
right so we don't really know so I mean
obviously I've talked to a few other
councils chairs of infrastructure around
setting up compost and they all seem
quite keen and one of the things is is
grabbing kitchen waste and taking that
out of the red bin and the reason is so
that the Redmond doesn't get smelly
you've got a separate collection all
those options are available but if we
don't know at the end of the day we're
actually saving money because this
hundred dollars
tax rate here still sits there
um it's it's it's tough so that's just
one of the things I just a bit uneasy
about uh Council cracker um thank you Mr
chair um I share your unas
um about these things but I would like
to note that
um the national Waste Management
strategy hit the Dr in its draft format
um is already stating things like
um curbside compost
um
um Organics help
um curbside collection of food scraps
and compostable type stuff required
nationally required by 2035 so whether
or not we
uh find that economic or efficient to do
so is going to be out the window we're
going to have to do it anyway so so
doing that if we reduce what's going to
the landfill as far as green stuff yeah
are we going to see a reduction in the
ETS
and
things to use costs will reduce but our
collection rubbish collection curbside
collection receptacles
Administration all of that will rise so
really like if it's a cost-effective
exercise you're looking for it's
unfortunately not going to be that okay
we'll throw out the signs uh part of the
challenge with the etcs is the cost of
the credits Rising as well okay but yeah
no no we'll we'll just wait we'll wait
yeah
that's right yeah we'll just do we'll
see if we're back here well I don't know
Mr cheers
I was a bit worried about the red bricks
because they wouldn't um come into the
stuff that would go surely to the
landfill they're actually recoverable
materials
laughs circular economy
okay right any more questions for Peter
um before we go into a workshop yeah
right we have four recommendations
um there that we received the solar
waste update report note the updated
waste to landfill data
note the advice from any in MFE
on the uh waste minimization plan and it
does not require a full review until
2026 and note the staff will assess
whether a full review is required of the
total MMP
subject to the government Finance
finalizing the national Waste Management
strategy so I can put all those four
resolutions to ever moved you moved
seconded put the motion all those in
favor
aye against that's carried
um can I someone move that we go into PE
mode
um councilor Cricket singing the Miss
Cook
um
I'm just going to
the stream is
it's not just